Rob Kardashian reportedly Falls to lower
$20,000 child support payments to his ex
blac chyna
woman according to multiple reports Rob
can no longer afford to pay those
thousands in child support and his
stance is that he doesn't need to
because China is a millionaire he has a
point she has a lot of money coming in
but apparently Rob has not been seen on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians that's
affecting his income and of course since
the summer when China and them filed all
that restraining order things things
have just been very different for Rob
he has joint custody and they've been
fighting for that for a dream I mean but
China seems to be on the up-and-up with
her last brand her brand deals Tyga is
paying child support for six-year-old
King Cairo
things just seem to be looking a lot
better for China than Rob right now of
course we're not you know really in his
finances so we don't know but this is
all that's been reported I mean I think
he has a valid point if she's the one
making more money doesn't it kind of
make sense that he would have to pay
less or at least pay what he can right
of course this is all you know something
that Rob and China are gonna have to
work on on their own but we want to know
should Rob Kardashian's decrease in
income reflect a decrease in his child
support payments let us know and let's
keep that conversation going and on the
topic of Rob and being a dad he's kind
of we've heard turning into a hot dad
yeah I mean one thing about Rob when he
becomes reclusive he Slim's down and I
think since dream has you know come in
his life he's made a really big
lifestyle change he's not one of those
dads that has the dad bod and the belly
he's someone who is you know making that
change for the good yeah in October a
source told et that the reality star has
said has really lost some serious pounds
they were guessing anywhere from 30 to
50 that's a lot it is Alya
they told us quote he's got his
priorities in check first and foremost
he is therefore dream and he knows that
to do that he needs to be healthy I
think what Rob being slimmed down and
more private I mean it's just better for
his overall well-being we're not seeing
as many rants from him he's spending a
lot more time with family I just always
thought Rob was someone who's a family
guy this is the Rob that we know and
love exactly we don't love that Rob from
July when he was posting those crazy
pictures of China that was crazy yeah it
was a lot that they were dealing with
but one thing about
like we said families first Khloe and
Rob seems to be on better terms now we
know with her evacuating from those
California wildfires that she went to
Rob's house so I mean things seem to be
looking up on that side of things but of
course things are still really messy
with the blow out of China and just this
big conversation of child support and
where they stand is co-parents yeah okay
do we think Rob is better staying out of
the spotlight or is this hurting him
financially I'm gonna say it may be
hurting him a little bit I love that
he's private I do too if he should stay
out of the spotlight but we also want to
know if you think Rob and China should
just go ahead and settle their child
support battle right that's something
for the court to handle but of course
Rob seems to be turning his life around
do we think that the drama is just
heating up between him and China
hopefully it's not but let's keep the
conversation going across social I'm at
Kourtney underscore tezo know and I'm at
Halle underscore Stephen
all right guys until next time we've got
you covered for your pop culture fix
you